well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages as they come in
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
broadcaster and journalists rachel
johnson
and the financial times is whitehall
editor sebastian payne
great to see both of you lots to talk
about as well so let's check out the
front pages
starting with the guardian it reports
that the indian
variant of covert 19 will become the
dominant strain
in the uk within days which could pose a
threat
to the final loosening of restrictions
on june the 21st
reporting that some vaccine skeptics
have now been convinced to take the kova
jab the metro declares
at last they get the point the daily
mail's big splash though says
pretty much the opposite now vaccine
refuse next threaten freedom
the telegraph hears that eu ministers
will announce on wednesday that britons
will be able
to travel to the continent without the
need for tests or quarantine
as long as they have a vaccine passport
the daily mirror says the return of
hugging and indoor gatherings has
brought
joy to millions of people and in other
news the financial times understands the
cabinet is deeply divided over the terms
of a possible post-brexit trade deal
with
australia we're still waiting for a
couple of newspapers we will bring them
to you as we get them but let's get the
thoughts of rachel johnson and sebastian
payne
and rachel we've got this strange
situation uh where we unlock
uh with this fear of a new variant i
mean you couldn't make it up could you
i know i mean we we don't need to
talk about rain on the parade because
it's been pouring across most of the
country this was supposed to be
a happy day of hugs hospitality and
future holidays and we saw those
images of many hundreds of people brits
arriving in portugal looking
happy and sunny and and celebrating
anniversaries or the end of cancer
treatments
but the papers are all taking different
lines on this
um you know the telegraph is very has
always been
a very let's crack on and you know they
run obviously pieces by mark harper or
and other mps from the covid recovery
group like steve baker
but there is this issue now as to
whether
as the vaccine works why don't we just
get on with it what are we waiting for
and the guardian is you know science-led
very cautious always has been throughout
the pandemic
the papers are you know always following
in their past so the guardian's very
cautious the the male is is taking a
slightly different tack which is
that the unlock could be in jeopardy
by these people who are not having the
vaccine and these are the people who are
mainly ending up in hospital in places
like bolton
um so it's it's a very messy picture
tonight
and i think what we've got to focus on
is whether the data will show in the
next couple of weeks
whether indian variant is so dangerous
that we do have to pause on the great
unlock on the june the 21st
and i think we know we're seeing the
government injecting notes of
caution uh throughout the day and
yesterday when it comes to that
it's going to be very hard when it comes
to june the 21st um
if the government led by the prime
minister has to
disappoint everybody once again as he
did when they cancelled christmas
uh a few months ago absolutely and the
health secretary speaking in the commons
today
sebastian making the point that this is
not just don't think this is just bolton
and blackburn with darwin
this is now in 86 local authority areas
that have more than
five cases and also using this
opportunity as he did yesterday
to stress that the people in hospital in
bolton
are often those who could have had the
vaccine they are eligible
and chose not to do so which is the
point made in the daily mail
and also made in the metro as well why
has he chosen this opportunity
to to make that point so clearly
well i think where we're at with this
new variant of coronavirus is that it is
going to become the dominant variant
within the uk that's what the scientific
evidence
suggests because it is much more
transmissible than the previous kent
variant that overtook the original
variant of chronovirus that came from
wuhan in china
so the real question now is not does the
individual spread because as you said
it's now being detected
in all parts of the country it's
spreading very quickly but the real
question we don't know the answer to is
just how much more transmissible is it
if it's 30 more transmissible that may
not actually affect the unlocking
schedule that badly
if it's 50 more transmissible that is a
big problem and at the moment we just
don't have the data
and the next two weeks are going to be
absolutely crucial for that there's been
all sorts of analysis by various
scientists
trying to get to the bottom of it the
answer is we really just don't know but
what we do know about this new variant
is that the vaccines
are very effective against it and i
think that's why matt hancock was so
clear in the house of commons today
you have to get the jab because the
majority of people who are in hospital
in bolton
one of the hot spots for this new
variant and we're all eligible for the
virus and hadn't taken it so i think
really
that is where the big effort is going to
be over the next two weeks and we've
seen that i think
six thousand two hundred people in
bolton took jobs over the weekend
there's been reports of
accuser vac stations that is around the
town the government
has set up new vaccination clinics has
extended the hours so
they really are throwing the kitchen
sink to see vaccines can get this thing
under control if they do then things
will look a little bit
brighter in terms of that big unlocking
rachel was talking about on june the
21st
but i do think where we're at with this
new value and we always knew
this could happen unfortunately you know
whenever the prime minister set out his
unlocking schedule he always said the
fourth test was going to be
there are no new variants of concern and
unfortunately that's exactly what we
have now
so i think there's a good chance june
the 21st could go ahead with more
unlocking
but masks and social distancing will be
required
for a longer period of time because of
that extra transmissibility so at the
moment
it's really the state putting all hands
on deck doing the testing
doing the vaccines and we just have to
hold our breath and for the next two
weeks
to see is that effective or not and that
will dictate what happens this summer
yes that might seem like quite a good
compromise to satisfy all
uh how you're saying june the 21st might
play out but i do think rachel that the
the first paragraph of the guardian
might shock people that
the covet variant first detected in
india will become the dominant strain in
the uk
within days after cases rose by more
than
75 since thursday and we we had jonathan
worth again in the comments today
likening our border security to a sieve
because we didn't put india on the red
list
uh early enough do you do you think that
is a criticism that the government will
be listening to
well i think that's a criticism that has
been put to the government
um continuously since the indian variant
started being the dominant variant but i
think that the actual
total number of cases is still not
enormous i think it's in the region of
what two and a half thousand or
something like that
um compared to what we saw before i mean
the problem is
pointed out it really depends how
transmissible it is
he's right to point out they are
throwing the kitchen sink at this and
essentially i think we've come down to
this
if we want to get towels on sun lounges
the government has got to get jabs into
arms i think that our holiday season uh
the great british summer abroad
as part from our staycations here is
going to be absolutely dependent on
people coming forward
also i might add downloading the nhs app
this is really important i think this is
a backdoor covered passport
i'm all in favorite i've downloaded it
it shows i've had my first jab it says
that astrazeneca it says which batch
now in a in a week's time it will show
i've had two
in theory all being going to plan if the
eu is going to open up
green list us that means that people
like me and whoever else has had their
job i.e
most of the country could in theory go
on holiday
if the conditions are right if obviously
if the virus is not
raging in the country that you're
destined for and the ryrus isn't raging
here
so you know it's not all doom and gloom
so i would just
i think everybody should you know bank
the
the benefits of today go and get the jab
and keep our fingers crossed that the
vaccine continues to be
completely effective as it is so far
proved with very few exceptions in
people in hospital in bolton i think
there are five who've had the
vaccine but have ended up in hospital
but their actual prior conditions and
underlying conditions
are uncertain so at the moment the news
is still
incredibly good and i think we've got to
feel confident
that we are on track with this with the
road map and with the unlocking but i
think seb might be right on the on the
masks in the distancing
that is something i think we could put
up with for a bit longer yes
that's interesting though because you
mentioned earlier the daily telegraph
and this idea
of europe accepting british tourists
after vaccination
the paper saying under the eu plan
member states would adopt
uniform entry requirements giving fully
vaccinated holidaymakers
from low-risk countries such as britain
unrestricted
entry which is fabulous news unless they
turn around and say actually
you've got the indian variant we don't
like the look of it you're not coming so
that's also why and also we're not eu
members
we're not eu members either so that's
two good reasons for them
to decide baby to keep us out this
summer okay
um just one final one final thought then
daily mirror
um the sort of montage of hope which is
rachel's theme sebastian
joy for millions is covered rules are
lifted to allow hugs and indoor meetups
it is only when you see pictures like
this you realize how much you've been
missing
and how much you've not been allowed to
do for so long don't you think
i do agree with that um i've i've had
one kobe job and i've been very
blessed today to be able to go out for
lunch an actual restaurant which is a
completely
overwhelming experience having not seen
the inside
of an ichiri for such a long time or had
a meal that's not been cooked in my own
kitchen and then i went to the pub this
evening
and to me to work contact and again both
these experiences were quite
extraordinary and it's great to see that
people are taking advantage of this
and everyone i've seen out and about in
london today has done it in that
responsible way
that boris johnson has talked about and
i think that is the crucial thing and i
think
because of this variant people will
exercise caution they won't be
breaking all the rules entirely and but
i think there is a question of fatigue
here and i think if that june the 21st
day does get pushed back
for relaxing or restrictions you know
the country's been through so much in
the past 18 months we shouldn't forget
that
when you see these pictures of people
being allowed to hug or shake hands for
the first time
it's just a reminder of how weird this
whole situation has been and i think
that's something the government's going
to have to combat with that if these
restrictions go on if
god forbid we end up having more local
lockdowns or what having to deal with
this new variant
i think the adherence rate is going to
be a big struggle in the future here but
generally rachel
today is roughly good news rachel i know
you want to come in we're we're already
over
i just want to say sebastian well done
for coming in after pub and lunch out
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now rachel johnson and
sebastian payne so
sebastian to the ft then uh a ferocious
split tell us more yes this is a great
story about my colleagues peter foster
and george parker about
a ferocious fight within cabinet about a
trade deal
with australia and this is meant to be
the first big post-brexit trade deal
that the government has signed because
all the other trade deals so far have
been so-called rollover deals which
essentially maintaining
the relationship that was had that we
had when we were members of the eaves
this is meant to be
part of a big bold new era but what
we're seeing now on the story of the ft
is the real world trade-offs involved
with doing such tr we're doing such
deals and basically the spit you've got
is between the farming lobby on the one
side represented by
george eustis the environment secretary
and michael gove the cabinet office
minister
versus the economic trading side which
is liz trust the trade secretary on the
other and
the real question is are we going to
allow australian quota free access to
our agricultural markets
if we do that there's big concerns it
could prove ruinous for the uk's farming
market
but if we don't do that then there's
probably not going to be a trade deal so
this one's going to come right down
to what boris johnson thinks on this
deal and we quote in the paper
senior government officials who say they
have no idea which way the promise is
going to
go but which way he does go it's going
to be so indicative of what this trip
new trading era looks like
are we going to do lots of free trade
deals with countries and
have potential problems with our markets
at home or are we going to water them
down
and not really do any trade deals of
significance at all so
in terms of government policy it really
is a fascinating one
rachel that leaves you with 30 seconds i
know you wanted to do harry but do you
want to also talk about this story too
so you pick
i would just make just a couple of
points i think that geography is really
important and also
as said pointed out with farmers the
farmers are concentrated in welsh and
scotland wales and scotland i can't see
a prime minister of the union during
this particular
state of affairs wanting to do much to
destabilize them and undermine their
livelihoods
point two why does nobody talk about the
fact that
i know i bang on about this when i do
the press review but australia is what
four and a half thousand miles away the
european
the european trading block is 22 miles
away i thought we were supposed to
becoming a carbon neutral net zero
economy and yet we're
we're importing thousands and thousands
from thousands and thousands of miles
away none of it really makes sense
what we need is a tariff-free non-tariff
barriers between
us and the eu as well as what we're
planning with list trust does all over
the world i mean
they may get tariff free trade deal or
they may not but the non-tariff barriers
to trade with australia and new zealand
are absolutely enormous
the battle rages on doesn't it so he
said we'll see you both at half past
eleven thank you both very much indeed
rachel and sebastian
thank you top story